Speaker 1: The COVID pandemic in the United
States is becoming more and more politically red.
A year ago, we wondered Would this happen?
And then six months ago we said this will
probably happen. And then three months
ago we said the data is showing that this
is starting to actually happen. But now it's not
only completely undeniable the degree to which in
the United States, COVID has become a Republican
killer, a Republican virus disproportionately
is quite stunning and overwhelmingly the COVID
deaths are happening in counties that Donald Trump
won and presumably, logically, overwhelmingly, it
is Trump voters who are dying from COVID at much
higher rates than Biden voters now. Would it be
enough to influence an election at a congressional
district level in a state federally? Really
still a question mark in terms of the math. But
as we've looked at with hypothetical numbers from
Florida a few months ago, if this continues to be
disproportionately a virus that kills Republicans
in the United States because Republicans are
disproportionately unvaccinated, it actually
could come to make a difference. For example,
in something like the Florida gubernatorial
election, it's a bit of a stretch, but it's
possible. But let's look at the numbers that we
have now. First, the New York Times has a really
good piece on this, which shows how the Partizan
gap has grown and grown and grown since January
1st, where it was only slightly more likely in
January that the COVID deaths were in the Trump
counties rather than the Biden counties. Now
remember, this is a chart of COVID death rates.
So for people saying, well, there's more people
or fewer people, no, no, no, this is the rate
per 100000 people. In January, there was a
slightly higher rate of death in Trump voting
counties than Biden counties. That gap has spread
and spread is starting around mid-September. It
has increased dramatically to the point where now,
as you can see here, the cumulative death rate
is under 200 deaths per 100000 people in Biden
counties. And it is rapidly approaching 300 deaths
per 100000 people in Trump counties. That is a
huge, huge difference. Now there have been many
attempts, I guess I would call them by various
right wingers of different stripes to explain this
difference away by saying, Well, the difference
is whether in those places or. The difference is
age in these places in Trump versus Biden
counties. But when you examine the data, it's
not supported by fact. And as it's pointed out in
the New York Times article about these numbers,
if the difference was due to weather or age, we
would have seen that Partizan split last year,
but instead we are seeing a dramatic increase
in that Partizan split over the last few months.
What we are seeing is a shift. In what determines
who is most likely to die, and I'll tell you what
I mean by that at the start of the pandemic, we've
talked about this now, we've said this before.
The deaths were most likely to be happening in the
places that had, we would call it the misfortune
of being early infection sites because of the
direct flights to and from the early infected
regions of China and some countries in Europe,
like Italy. So you had New York, New York, New
Jersey, you had Boston with that early conference
and many nonstop flights to Asia, for example,
and a few other spots that early that was what
indicated what who was getting hit the hardest.
We now have a very different situation.
We now know about how the virus spreads.
We now have it everywhere, so to speak. And
we now have vaccination widely available. And
now the biggest distinguishing factor between the
Trump counties and the Biden counties is the level
of vaccination. Forty percent of Republican adults
are not vaccinated. Only 10 percent of Democratic
registered adults are unvaccinated. That is why
the COVID deaths are concentrated not in major
metropolitan areas, but rather on a rate basis.
Remember, we're talking about a rate of death.
The deaths are increasingly concentrated, where
conservatives tend to live more suburban and
rural areas because they have a far lower rate of
vaccination. Now, it doesn't just apply to deaths.
If you look at cases, we are seeing a big Partizan
gap there as well. It was biggest in August
and now, thanks to the national decline in
COVID cases, although the last ten days make
us wonder whether cases are going to go back
up, we now see still a Partizan gap on cases,
but a slightly smaller one than we had in August.
So COVID is getting more and more politically
red. It's not Republic. It's not a surprising
thing that we are seeing this increasingly
ravaged Republicans at this point in time. And
there is a good chance. I mean, even when we say
look at the death rate in this Biden county,
it stands to reason that because Republicans
are disproportionately unvaccinated, that even
in Biden counties, the deaths happening there
skew towards the Republican Party. So every
country is different in the United States.
We increasingly are seeing this as a Republican
pandemic. Does it mean liberals can't die? Of
course not. The virus doesn't discriminate on
the basis of politics. However, vaccination is
the greatest indicator as to where we are
seeing the virus kill more versus fewer people,
and it is Republicans who are disproportionately
unvaccinated. So we're going to keep following
these numbers. But it is a trend we expect it
is the trend we started to see and the degree to
which we are now seeing it is quite stunning. Do
Republicans care even if they don't care about the
people that are dying? Maybe they don't. Maybe
they do. I don't know. You'd have to ask them
at some point. Don't you think that they would
wake up and say, Hey, this is this is killing our
voters more than it is killing their voters? And
merely from the perspective of like a pragmatic
election strategy. At some point, you
would imagine they would start saying,
Hey, you know, I've been like, This isn't good.
Maybe we should go and get ourselves vaccinated.